do you expect to find Organics at all
yeah definitely so benu is a CA type
asteroid which so it's carbonaceous so
it's got lots of carbon it's thought to
be what we call a very primitive
asteroid which means that it's got the
the very first materials that were
formed around the Sun and these are the
kind of objects where we found amino
acids right precisely yeah yeah so we
fully expect to find amino acids in
there the building blocks of protein and
the building blocks of life the high
abuse the two Mission which um did a
similar thing and came back just a
couple years ago they've even found one
of the nuclear bases of RNA who wow
you've got all the building blocks for
Life Within These objects and that's
part of the reason we want to look at
them what we really want is something to
crawl out of it when we open it up that
would be very cool and you know it would
be just it's trapped in the capsule so
we never
know